mark here we are in beaverton this
morning not just you and I President
Obama is here we're talking about this
trade agreement and there are protesters
in Portland right now who don't want to
see this happen so what does all of this
mean to you a man who produces a whole
lot of shoes in Vietnam yes well we
actually produce use all around the
world but mainly in the asia-pacific
region which is really the topic of this
trade deal it's important for us to be
part of this conversation it's an honor
to have the president with us today to
talk about trade a really important
topic for Nike Nike was a company that
was born and succeeded based on the
ability to trade globally this is an
important topic we feel it's critical
for the United States to have a 21st
century trade agreement in place we feel
that for Nike it actually gives us the
opportunity to create jobs create jobs
because of savings that we think we
anticipate will be part of the TPP well
the critics say listen you make a shoe
in Vietnam a LeBron elite and you sell
it here for 320 bucks how much does it
cost to make that shoe because people
who don't know sure feel like you're
making a whole lot of money in the
middle yeah well these the numbers on
the shoes in terms of what they cost to
make they they're actually a lot higher
than what most people report the the the
value that we put in shoes is through
the technology that goes into making
those products advanced technology the
componentry the athletes that we work
with that give us the insights that
drive the innovation there's a lot of
factors that go into creating really
innovative products that resonate with
athletes and consumers so do people want
to pay for that you're in a position
right now where it's a race to the
bottom consumers are living in this
Walmart Amazon world where they want to
pay the lowest prices at the same time
they want minimum wage raised so how do
you marry the two as a manufacturer well
Nikes not a company that's born out of
creating products that are at discounted
rates for mass consumption we're
actually trying to create premium
innovative products that push the
envelope performance so that's really
what we're all about we have the
opportunity for that technology to
trickle down to be more accessible in
terms of price point shoes that are more
open to the broader consuming population
but for us it's it's a matter of really
pushing that innovation envelope and and
there's like I said there's a lot of
factors that go into that in general
would it make life a lot easier if you
manufactured here originally you made
your products in New England and it was
America that didn't want to be a
manufacturing country we wanted to be a
service-based country yeah i think
there's advantages to actually making
product here and what we want to do is
actually develop it advanced
manufacturing to the state here where
it's viable where it's it makes sense
from a bottom line standpoint so we're
actually trying to create more choice
for consumers pushing our customization
personalization agenda getting product
to consumers more quickly these are all
advantages to having sourcing more local
how prohibited are the tariffs now for
you the tariffs are antiquated I mean
they the tariff legislation was created
in the 30s during the Great Depression
tariffs in our industry are generally
ten times what they are other consumer
products on average we feel that the
it's it's really an advantage to us if
we can get a break on the tariffs and in
terms of a modern as I said 21st century
trade agreement we can take those funds
and then leverage them to create modern
manufacturing here in the in the united
states this trade agreement doesn't go
through or fast-track doesn't these
10,000 jobs that you think you're gonna
create what happens none of them we're
good this the savings that will see from
the tariff reductions hopefully will
actually help to accelerate the advanced
manufacturing development work that
we're doing here in the united states so
i think it'll make
possible that we will create
manufacturing in the states right now
it's cost prohibitive but we need to
develop the technologies which were
committed to and it's it's a longer time
frame so this will actually greatly
shorten the time frame and allow us to
put those technologies in place to
actually ramp up manufacturing here in
the US you say that the law are the
tariffs are antiquated is it outdated or
antiquated that nike continues to get
beat up by this drama of politicians
saying or activists who are saying your
labor practices are inappropriate
overseas I mean that was an issue you
faced in the 90s but since then it seems
that you really cleaned up your game and
you're not getting credit for it yeah
we've made a massive commitment to
improving the working conditions in our
factories our contract factories i
should say around the world and very
proud of the progress that we've made in
many cases we are a case study in terms
of how a company can come in and
actually make tremendous headway in that
area and again i'm proud of that
progress i continue to see opportunities
to make improvements I don't think we're
there I'm not sure if we'll ever be
there where we really want to be
completely this is all about
transparency it's all about cooperation
and collaboration with others so are
these politicians like Bernie Sanders or
these activists are they miss informed
do they not know the current nike i
think that there is misperceptions and
dated views of nike in this area I point
you to the Harvard and Stanford case
study updates that have been put out
recently that will give you a good idea
of much of the progress that we've made
all right we talk about innovation and
technology that is very much Nikes brand
when you decided to get out of the
hardware game out of the FuelBand what
did you know you've got a very close
relationship with Tim Cook clearly you
know tech what is that telling us well I
think the wearables market will actually
continue to grow the Apple iWatch is a
good really first big step for them and
met
ways I think they were just seeing the
potential of that the wearables
represent we expect to be there not
making hard goods but actually being a
part of that experience being on those
devices and connecting to those
consumers through app development
through other experiences that are
digitally based and our goal is to
create a seamless connection to
consumers through commerce through
communication and through digital sport
experiences isn't that one under armours
doing with the two acquisitions three
excuse me three acquisitions that they
made they've now got 130 million people
in their digital ecosystem and one would
say that kind of leap frogged you yeah I
think what we're committed to this space
I feel really good about our position
right now we have record numbers of new
members of our digital community
happening every week so that's that
continues to grow the apps continue to
be developed the relationships and the
partnerships not just Apple but others
also continued to be developed and I'm
very bullish and again you have to look
at this isn't just about tracking and
sensing this is about the complete
experience because consumer has with
Nike through many different aspects of
digital when I think about the Nike
community I think about your
extraordinary premier athletes does that
continue to be the best way for Nike to
bet ten months ago we would be sitting
here and I would say you won Kevin
Durant that's the athlete to get but
that's a really risky bet if you're
always just gonna bet on athletes
because now we're looking and it seems
that Steph Curry's the winner well you
know it's it's it's about the
relationship we have with athletes that
relationship gives us the insights that
drives innovation it obviously
represents the brand to the consumers in
in in sports around the world so that's
important to us that's always been an
important part of our model as a company
I'm proud of the athletes that we have
proud of the success that they've had
continued to be very motivated by the
relationships that we have with the
athletes they're incredibly inspiring I
wouldn't trade places with anybody
a risk because if Tiger Woods doesn't
win does that mean nike loses not
necessarily know i think the winning and
losing is part of sports and we know
that not every athletes going to win
every time and and that's fun that's
what makes it interesting that's you
know if you had one athlete dominate
completely all the time I don't think it
would be quite as interesting at least
in New York a lot of people are talking
about the NBA contract in terms of
apparel adidas stepped out saying it
didn't help them sell shoes why do you
think it's interesting adidas stepped
out in terms of the jerseys the apparel
they're not going to be in that business
nike could be stepping in why does that
make sense for you since it didn't make
sense for adidas well I think it's how
we execute you know that has a lot to do
with the relationship I'm actually
incredibly excited about all our
relationships not just with the athletes
but with the league's and the governing
bodies of sport we have opportunities to
innovate and as you've seen many times
and you will you know going forward that
our ability to innovate and bring
something new to the game is is there
that's what motivates us that's what
drives us and for you what is the most
exciting thing happening at Nike right
now we're sitting here in a flying it
Empire yeah well you know I'm an
innovation geek I love sneakers I love
shoes I love products apparel and that's
what really ultimately drives Nike is
the innovation that we put into our
products and the relationship that we
have with those athletes and consumers
so that's what really gets me excited
this pipeline has never been as fault
does that mean I'm gonna see President
Obama walking in here with air Obama's
in about an hour uh well you know we
have a gift for President Obama yes it
is an amazing pair of shoes a
one-of-a-kind pair of shoes that we've
made here you made it here in the United
States you're in on campus which we can
do it's I can't describe it other than
say it's red white and blue it's very
American it's one-of-a-kind it will blow
your socks off mark congratulations
thank you so much
Erik schatzker marks about to kick it
literally with President Obama Stephanie
terrific stuff mark thank you very much
that as Nike CEO Mark Parker's